earlier this week we aired our Conan in
Israel special we're really proud of
that special and hope time you got a
chance to check it out we were really
thrilled with how it came out if you did
miss it not to worry just head to team
koco.com slash Israel you can watch the
entire episode in fact this is kind of
cool I've traveled my show to a bunch of
countries now I've gone to South Korea
Mexico Cuba Armenia and it's cool it's
become one of my favorite parts of doing
the show these days come to my country
next I'm sorry who said that it was me
please you must visit to my country next
Conan O'Brien who are you my name is
Francisco Google ionia and I am the
president of Bolivia Kwai
belivet way I've never heard of Bolivia
kweilyn ever heard of it yes believe
maguey it is a teeny country in between
Bolivia and Paraguay I brought a map
yeah okay I'm sorry sorry looks like you
just drew on a map with a sharpie that's
what it looks like anyway we would be if
you would come to believe away and shoot
one of your travelogue shows this is
weird I can't place your accent what
language do you speak in belivet way we
speak English but with this accent okay
what kind of accent is that Bolivia
okay look I'm sure Bulova Quay is a
lovely country but I'm just not sure
we're gonna be visiting please Conan we
modeled the entire country after United
States the form of government in but
little GUI is a hot dock receipt I'm
sorry what is a hoe stock recei every
single citizen in Bolivia Quay is the
host of their own shop yes for example
right now I'm shooting my show chillin
with Francisco hey thanks for chilling
with Francisco be sure to click the like
button and leave a comment after I talk
to Karen and O'Brien stay tuned for a
fun and easy recipe for fried cheese
balls
give me a favorite serve please please
don't shoot your show during my show too
late oh and my cameraman is the host of
his own show hey thanks for watching
jose shoots chili with francisco be sure
to click that like button and check the
comment section for a great fries cheese
balls recipe
and Jose's production assistant has her
own show
hi thanks for watching Jesse helps Jose
shoot Jose shoots chilling with
Francisco starting Jesse and Jose I'm
Jesse and I'm Jose Tommy not will be
breaking the top fried cheese bowels in
believing way we are special guests the
president can't wait love those fried
cheese balls
just stop it stop it right now you guys
are obsessed with fried cheese balls oh
yes
fried cheese balls are the official
delicacy of Bulova Quay every restaurant
in our country serves them theirs
McDowell's ours king boughs way vowels
bell kfb the peaceful bowels vowels bees
del vowels vowels and vowels vowels and
vowels bow we get it we get it
Oh would you like to try one no no God
look at that
no look I'm sure blivet way is very nice
I just don't think this is gonna work
out oh please we love America check out
our country's flag interesting flag sir
why do you have so many metals in
belivet way you'll receive a medal for
every pound move now socratic
Oh oh no oh no well what's what's what's
what's wrong I ate too many French
cheese bone
[Applause]
[Music]
and now we must all sing the bulimic way
in national anthem
first you must prepare the cheese before
you fry the cheese roll cheesy - that's
all the time we have and you like to go
very much that's right but you go guys
oh that's great
you